la tension semble être retombée ce
dimanche dans la vallée de la Maurienne
en Savoie ou des affrontements ont
opposé hier les forces de l'ordre aux
opposants de la future ligne TGV
Lyon-Turin les écologistes aujourd'hui
dans notre pays partent totalement en
vraie sont dans la provocation
permanente ainsi à la radicalité je
crois fond du fond du Torr à la cause
environnementale
c'est une manifestation interdite elle
est pas interdite pour le décorum elle
est pas interdite parce que le ministre
d'intérieur on a envie elle est
interdite parce qu'elle est dangereuse
parce qu'elle réunit des individus qui
sont des délinquants pas des militants
il faut faire respecter l'interdiction
d'ailleurs c'est le paradoxe de cet État
qui est nu qui qui gesticule parce qu'il
va rien se passer et il y a cette
confusion entre tenue depuis très
longtemps avec un collectif dont nous
appelons la dissolution et que nous
allons dissoudre les soulèvements de la
terre parce qu'il mène des opérations de
délinquance pas de militantisme et si
certains se battent en même temps contre
le train contre toute modernisation
contre toute avancée et bien on est
évidemment dans une impasse cet impact
c'est une impasse contre la France
contre notre modèle de civilisation la
première fois qu'on m'a parlé du lion
Touring j'avais rien contre je savais
pas de quoi on parlait quand on m'a
expliqué j'ai changé d'avis parce que
non seulement cette voie ferrée existe
donc améliorant là encore un peu et
surtout il faut y mettre plus le train
170 km de tunnel ça veut dire plus de
nuisances plus de camions dans cette
vallée et ce sont des écologistes qui
viennent oui je reviens à ma question en
Maurienne c'est aberrant pourquoi j'ai
pas écologique parce que on va sortir de
là-dedans une masse de terre qui
représente l'équivalent de cette
pyramide mais surtout surtout surtout
surtout
120 millions de mètres cubes d'eau par
an vont dévaler parce qu'on a fait un
trou Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est Raël
c'est-à-dire qu'il a oui c'est bien
connu
c'est à dire que il est ni député ni
rien il est là il a pas de mandat et
puis à la tête d'une secte bleue
qui soulève le plus d'interrogations par
d'abord son ses idées c'est un homme qui
est très proche d'une forme d'extrême
droite très radicale quasi suprématiste
et comme il a les moyens de ses idées je
le considère comme très dangereux est-ce
que vous serez prêtes à cacher quelqu'un
que votre mari vient de tuer et vous
qu'est-ce que vous seriez prête à vous
mettre à la drogue je vois pas l'intérêt
non parce que non non parce que tout va
être gâché non moi je suis déjà dans
Macron sifflé au Stade de France et
d'Eth hier soir sur la pelouse juste
avant la finale du Top 14 entre Toulouse
et La Rochelle est-ce que vous
accepteriez une maîtresse ah non ah non
et vous est-ce que vous accepteriez un
amant auparavant non
champion de France et roi du suspense un
22ème Bouclier de Brennus obtenu à
l'arraché pour l'équipe de Romane TAMAK
scène improbable le président Emmanuel
Macron buvant une bière d’une traite
face à des joueurs toulousains eux-mêmes
étonnés une image qui risque de faire
beaucoup parler
Emmanuel Macron a aussi annoncé à
l'entrée au Panthéon d'un homme mi-sac
Manouchian un symbole de la résistance
un communiste rescapé du génocide
arménien Missak manouchon est le premier
résistant étranger panthéonisé un
symbole pour tous les immigrés qui ont
pris part à la lutte contre l'occupant
nazie c'était malheureusement et qui on
donne malheureusement l'asile très vite
de manière un peu automatique et qu'en
réalité on ne connaît pas
quelle contraste par rapport à
évidemment à André Manoukian Marine Le
Pen je voudrais être sûr qu'elle a
vraiment couper les liens avec ses
anciens amis d'extrême droite j'en suis
pas certain voilà